this altitude this episode is brought to
you by fresh books thousands of
listeners and a lot of the contractors I
use and my readers use fresh books if
you've been thinking about turning your
part-time side business into a full-time
small business or big business for that
matter you may be feeling some extra
uncertainty these days and that's
obviously completely natural there are a
lot of questions that can come up how do
you create a professional appearance and
experience who can help you with support
how do you manage the billing and all of
that but still focus on the primary work
of your business and on growing your
business fresh books is an all-in-one
invoicing and accounting solution it
does a lot more than that that helps you
take your business from part-time to
full-time and it only takes minutes to
set up they have one of the best signup
flows in the business I've seen very few
better they have been helping people
turn their passions into small
businesses for 15 years and they can
help you too I've met the founders I've
looked at this product very closely with
automated invoicing billable time and
expense tracking and an intuitive
dashboard that ties it all together it's
like having a full time financial
assistant with you every step of the way
you can create customized and sent
branded and professional-looking
invoices in about 30 seconds you get
paid up to twice as fast with fees as
low as 1% using ACH payments on fresh
books it's a fast easy and secure way
for clients to pay you for your work and
pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets fresh books apart is
their award-winning toronto-based
customer service a real person picks up
fast and will help you until you are
completely satisfied and have your
questions answered there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world right now but
your ability to build a business that
you're passionate about that you're
proud of doesn't have to be one of those
things business owners all over the
world rate fresh books as the easiest
accounting software to use try it out
check it out for free for 30 days at
fresh books
dot-com / Tim just enter Tim Ferriss in
the how did you hear about a section
again that's fresh books calm / Tim to
check it out and try it for free for
30-days
one more time fresh books calm / Tim
this episode is brought to you by five
bullet Friday my very own email
newsletter it's become one of the most
popular email newsletters in the world
with millions of subscribers and it's
super super simple
it does not clog up your inbox every
Friday I send out five bullet points
super short of the coolest things I've
found that week which sometimes includes
apps books documentaries supplements
gadgets new self experiments hacks
tricks and all sorts of weird stuff that
I dig up from around the world
you guys podcast listeners and book
readers have asked me for something
short and action-packed for a very long
time because after all the podcast the
books they can be quite long and that's
why I created five little Friday it's
become one of my favorite things I do
every week it's free it's always gonna
be free and you can learn more at tim
dot blog forward slash friday
that's tim dot blog forward slash friday
i get asked a lot how I meet guests for
the podcast some of the most amazing
people I've ever interacted with and a
little known fact I've met probably 25%
of them because they first subscribed to
500 Friday so you'll be in good company
it's a lot of fun five bullet Friday is
only available if you subscribe via
email I do not publish the content on
the blog or anywhere else also if I'm
doing small in-person meetups offering
early access to startups beta testing
special deals or anything else that's
very limited I share it first with 500
Friday subscribers so check it out
Tim vlog forward slash Friday if you
listen to the podcasts very likely that
you'd dig it a lot and you can of course
easily subscribe any time so easy peasy
again that's Tim blog forward slash
Friday and thanks for checking it out if
the spirit moves you
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to perhaps the most impromptu
tap dancing version of the Tim Ferriss
show that you will hear I have with me
my friend Sam Harris I always enjoy
speaking with Sam we had originally
planned to do a session at South by
Southwest that has been cancelled and we
have been put into circumstances that
may require or encourage different
topics the plan had been meditation
psychedelics and dangerous ideas I said
to Sam before we hit record that I can
probably use a fair dose of at least the
first two in my life right now but Sam
we were deliberating what to talk about
and I'll tell you an embarrassing fact a
secret of sorts I have a deck of cards
that I thought could be a lifeline if
need be called three things which has
prompts of different questions that I
could ask you that I've wanted to ask
you anyway but how should we even frame
this conversation well first let me say
at this point I'm committed to producing
the worst episode of the Tim Ferriss
podcast ever aired so let's start there
I appreciate your heart your
hard-working ethic well I mean what's
amazing as you know I also have a
podcast and I'm finding obviously
speaking a lot about the coronavirus and
our our in-depth response to it and all
of the all the attendant concerns but
there's just this bewilder and
experience of having one's core
interests sidelined and even just
seeming patently inappropriate to air I
mean I have podcasts on several topics
that I just can't drop in the current
environment actually not because they're
they're too frivolous and tone-deaf in
that way but because they're they're on
yet other emergencies or or grim topics
that that I can't imagine anyone wants
to pay attention to now like you know
nuclear war
or the prospect of nuclear war and
nuclear terrorism I mean who the hell
wants to think about that right now and
so yeah and to say nothing of things
like you know psychedelics I mean who I
don't know about you but this does not
seem like a moment to do a whopping dose
of mushrooms or anything else with with
an invading virus lumen in every corner
of the world I mean to talk about set
and set in it's it's the wrong both yeah
yep
I agree so I feel like we should just
have a conversation and I think mind you
I should remind you of your tweet about
who was it some like you named the
person but someone in your circle said
you know we should now we should drop
you know we should take I lost no I said
I think it's time to it take some peyote
and talk to the Pangolin right so that
that elicited a troll ish tweet from me
on earth you saw that come across your
radar okay I think you bite of what was
your response I said just spoke to the
Pangolin unfortunately he's working for
the bat and the bats an [ __ ] yep yeah
it is a tricky time to track down spirit
animals in the psychedelic astral plane
for sure you have to do contact tracing
right so I have these cards surrounding
me I am also committed to making the
worst episode of the Tim Ferriss show
since its inception which would match a
lot of things that are hitting their
worst since inception moments but let me
just throw a few out there or one to
begin with and we'll see where that goes
and you can completely veto and we can
take it in a different direction sure
what are three things you have learned
about fear that is the question on the
card in general or in we're based on
recent events in general in your life or
current events any way you want to take
it yeah a couple things one is that
it is certainly necessary you wouldn't
want to be without it you wouldn't want
to have your amygdala removed and and
simply be insensitive to the fear-based
initial response to stimuli or even
ideas right so it's it's a necessary
part of the toolkit for obvious
evolutionary reasons and as well as
personal ones and and many people
imagine that if you get deep into
meditation or some other spiritual
practice the goal is to get rid of fear
and and other classically negative
states of mind entirely and that's
really not the way I view it so you you
wouldn't want to never feel it again but
you want to be able to stop feeling it
whenever it's no longer useful and it
really is only useful for a very short
period of time I mean it's it's it's a a
signal of salience more than anything
else I mean it's it's negatively valence
salience but what do you mean actually I
should say that the it's often thought
that the amygdala it really is just the
kind of the fear center and doesn't do
much of anything else it's not just that
it really is more the the salience
centers it's it's when you're noticing
information that really needs to be
emotionally and behaviorally relevant
you know in the moment so your response
to scary faces you know that via classic
stimuli you know you turn the corner and
you and you see somebody staring at you
and they look terrifying you know that
instantaneous visceral perception of
threat you don't want to lose that right
I can't imagine you know being a social
primate you know however much I meditate
wanting to completely lose that but what
you you you want to then be able to do
is let go of it the moment you're known
or served by seeing the world through
that lens and for so much of our fear
that that you know then grades into the
ordinary anxiety it's just not useful
you know it's just it's not useful to
have
stress of that sort become the the mood
music of your life and and which is what
happens to so many of us it's happening
to millions and millions of us in this
moment around this pandemic so I mean
the first thing I guess there are two
things there the first thing is that you
you still want this this is not this is
a gift this is not a curse
but it becomes a curse the moment you
can't actually let go of it you know
more or less on demand and and you want
to be able to do that so that's
certainly two things the third thing I
guess the third thing I would ask that
you actually can do that I mean it's not
you know mindfulness is the method by
which you would do that and so that you
know there's a path to being able to do
that more and more and more and more
quickly can you think of a moment for
your situation in which you were
experiencing acute anxiety or fear and
used mindfulness as an intervention
could you describe it if so oh yeah yeah
that happens a lot and it's happening a
lot in this circumstance I guess I'm the
one I remember very clearly was sort of
the the beginning of my taking the the
kovat problem seriously and I forget
when this was at the end of February at
some point so somewhere in like February
25th or so and I had ordered an iPad
since some weeks before when I was when
I was truly oblivious to what was going
on and you know it finally came and I
I'm again at this point I'm thinking
thoughts like wait a minute how long
does the virus live on a surface I see
that this thing is you know freshly
minted in Shanghai and sent to me you
know after they've clamped down on me
the Luhan problem you know I don't so I
don't know what the the likelihood is
that I'm now opening a box of virus but
you know I've decided to open it after
letting it sit for some days so I'm
opening this box and I realized that I'm
I'm double minded about it and in some
ways just kind of in bad faith with the
whole project so like on the one hand
I'm taking precautions right I'm wearing
you know wearing gloves but I'm not
wearing a mask I'm opening it carefully
I've got you know I've decided to just
wipe this iPad down with alcohol wipes
so on some level I'm treating it like
medical waste but on another level I
recognize wait a minute I'm not doing
this even remotely the way I would do it
if I knew there was corona virus in this
box right I'm so on some level I'm kind
of going through the motions and I'm
assuming that this is fine and then I'm
actually being crazy and this is kind of
a pantomime of preparedness as opposed
to the real thing and it is the
experience of almost being double-minded
like me like the person who's opening
the box is not the whole person and
there's there's another part of me
looking on saying you're not really
doing this correctly and as witnessed by
the fact that I'm standing in the middle
of my living room and my kids are like
you know 15 feet away and it's just not
like I just you know flash I recognized
okay you you're doing all of this you've
got the alcohol wipes oh you got the
gloves on you're acting like someone who
thinks he's overreacting right you're
kind of you're just again in bad faith
you're not you're not actually unified
as just a behavioral system and at that
moment I just got kind of flooded with
anxiety over this whole kind of the the
scope of the whole crisis like how
difficult it had been for me to convince
myself that the problem was worth
responding to all the people I'm in
dialogue with you know in my family
personally and in my social circle and
then just in the public in the kind of
public conversation that was was
starting around it and I just realized
how difficult it was going to be to
change my own behavior and for everyone
else around us to change our behavior in
a way that was actually going to be
effective and but at that moment it just
like it was a very punctate experience
of it just you know just cortisol which
was like oh [ __ ] you
and you were you you do not have your
[ __ ] together at all
right you're in the middle of your
living room opening a box of virus you
so you sort of think so and you've but
you haven't done you know it's like yeah
again my kids are like 15 feet away from
me at this point and so I just felt like
a complete [ __ ]
and but it was at that moment where I
thought okay I am actually still pretty
early you know the I took you know a
kind of you know I don't know how to
quantify the risk but like okay wake up
and actually get your game together here
and at that moment you know from that
moment onward the the anxiety is no
longer useful
right like I'm the to be stressed out
and once I have right the message has
been delivered it's a hundred percent
delivered and the only time it's useful
as any kind of holding pattern for me is
when there's still significant
uncertainty about what to do so when
you're at the border between what you
know you're doing and what you you know
don't understand and you're trying to
figure out what you should do you can't
figure out what your policy is then
anxiety is the thing that's gonna get
you to keep focusing and figure it out
but once you figure it out once you
realize okay and you open the boxes
outside you wear gloves you you know let
them sit for however many days you
decide to let them sit you wipe things
down that can be wiped down there's no
reason to be adrenaline at all doing any
of that stuff as long as you know what
you're doing right yeah and so that's
and and again mindfulness is really the
method by which you can let go of it
because you you notice the thoughts you
notice this peripheral physiology of you
know just that the the felt sense of
being anxious and you notice the
connection between those things and once
you once you just let the thoughts go
and just become willing to just feel the
raw sensations of anxiety the sensations
lose their their psychological import
them it's just again it just feels like
you know indigestion or itching or you
know a pain in the knee or anything else
that has no real meaning it's just it's
just sensation
degrades over a half-life of really
seconds I mean it does not stay around
long so anyway that's and that's the
experience I remember and you know
obviously they've been many like that
but you know it's useful for a few
seconds and it's necessary for a few
seconds but then beyond that you're just
resurrecting it by what you're doing
with your mind in the next moment I find
your app and I've said this to you
before waking up app very useful for
training for this and in a number of the
meditations which are least in the
introductory course sequenced in a
logical progression as sort of building
progression much like you might hope to
learn a language starting with the basic
building blocks and working your way up
there's a there's a phrase that you use
in a number of them with the snap of
fingers which is just to drop it right
and not not viewing that as a hill to
climb not viewing that as something that
requires a tremendous amount of
conscious effort it's something that can
happen in an instant when you're opening
this box I'm glad you said iPad I was
wondering if there's just a box of bats
or something okay I might as well have
been yeah got to cook those at a minimum
of 400 degrees and then is there
something you say to yourself in that
moment to try to defuse the no longer
useful anxiety is there anything that
you point your attention towards or is
it just a reflexive active of
mindfulness much like someone like Jocko
can reassemble God knows how many
weapons in the dark being woken up you
know a half hour early so at 4 a.m.
how long does it take to clean and
reassemble the gun of mindfulness right
yeah well you so I mean there's there
are reflections and and concepts you
know peanut pieces of language that can
be useful I don't at this point tend to
carry many of those around I mean I
might spontaneously think something that
is useful I mean
a bit of self-talk but generally
speaking it really is just watching the
present thought kind of unravel I mean
the moment I notice I'm thinking without
noticing a thought itself as an
appearance in consciousness the moment I
know some I identified with in this case
an anxious thought mm then I just I can
see the the the thought itself unwind in
this larger condition which is just you
know open awareness and so it is a kind
of non conceptual you know immediate
pivot to that or or it's just
recognizing the circumstance you know
from that point of view that happens you
know it happens whenever it happens you
know and there's there's you know on
some level is not even when I say you
know one can do this on demand on one
level that's true but the experience of
actually doing it is is not really the
experience of control is really just the
experience of spontaneously recognizing
what's actually already true of your
mind and you and you can't you know you
remember when you remembers I went when
do you on some level there's no
accounting for why that moment dawns
then and not a moment before or a moment
later but it's just a moment I notice oh
okay I'm you know that's a thought then
the whole the process starts without you
know without me having to really get
behind myself and push in some way but
you it's it's totally useful to think
certain thoughts as a kind of antidote I
mean they're the people who have
developed whole methods around that was
a kind of a stylized reflection I think
you did you have you have Byron Katie on
your podcast I haven't I should I've
spent some time with her but I haven't
had her on the podcast I do find a lot
of value in her framework I mean yeah
series of questions and prompts and so
on that she uses yeah I don't know why I
don't know why I thought I'd heard you
speak with her at some point but yeah I
mean she hasn't been on my podcast
either but I've met her and
never spent much time with her work but
I know she does work this way we show
you she'll ask questions like you know
how do you know that's true which just
throws everything back on this this
basic fact that in in most cases the
thing we're worrying about hasn't
happened right it's still hypothetical
and we're worrying about it as though
you know that the hangman's noose is
already around our necks and you know
this is this is a fait accompli and
there's there's nothing we can do about
it and you know if you actually focus on
the present you know there really is
just whatever is given there and your
thoughts about the past and the future
and you know that it does expose a you
know interesting fact which is you know
you know either you can do something
about the problem you're worried about
or you can't and in either case is
you're stressing out about it really
warranted I mean if you can do something
about it well then just do something
about it you know solve the problem and
if you can't do anything about it well
then you know why suffer twice right I
mean you're suffering now before the
thing arrives and then you're gonna
suffer when it arrives you know so on
some level you can decide to just you
know be with even if something really is
a fait accompli
I mean if even even if a bad thing is
going to happen and there's no way of
avoiding it I mean one we also know that
we're we're very bad prognosticators
about our future states of happiness and
and misery right so we tend to totally
exaggerate how how much we're going to
be shifted with respect to our
moment-to-moment well-being we
overestimate how positive something's
going to be and we overestimate how
negative something's going to be and you
know as we know from a lot of psychology
and behavioral economics you know people
return to baseline fairly quickly even
from extraordinarily bad and good things
happening to them and most of the time
spent you know worrying about even
objectively bad things is
is is still fairly delusional I mean
we're just not actually mapping the
future that the future that will in fact
arrive at some point sim I'm just
curious to know seeing the last it's
arbitrary last few months last year what
have you changed your mind on what
positions have you modified or reversed
what insights if you had that if
rendered past beliefs
perhaps outdated what have you changed
your mind on in the last few months or
year that come to mind that are really
it could be anything material or other
ones well I I feel like under the
pressure of this pandemic many things
are shifting for me I think it's
probably happening for for most people
but I'm not actually consciously scoring
all the changes you know as they're
happening but I'm noticing a shift in my
orientation and maybe I would shift back
but for instance you know as you know
I've spent a lot of time criticizing
what I perceived be bad ideas and and
even criticizing the people who I
perceived to be you know purveyors of
bad ideas and so in political space I
you know I can get into some fairly
heated arguments with people and with
the possible exception of President
Trump I've pulled back from I were the
actual you know with a noted exception
of President Trump I've pulled back from
that a lot just because it strikes me as
as really counterproductive you know so
there are people who are saying some
truly idiotic things about coronavirus
and insofar as I've engaged them in
public I've tried to be you know fairly
I'm a fairly light touch and then you
know I've done a lot of kind of private
you have attempted you know several
private exorcisms you know because I
haven't wanted to go after these people
in public and get them to just dig in
you know based on their own
you know egos or concerns about you know
not being shown to be wrong or whatever
it is and I must say that the results
are impressively mixed I mean I'm not
I've become less and less hopeful that
even fairly smart people are open to a
rational argument even when it would
would serve their interests and everyone
else's interests I mean it's the the
communication failures around this or
are pretty spectacular and I mean what's
one thing I've changed my mind about at
least provisionally I met I would love
to be proven wrong here but just as a
matter of being able to achieve some
kind of political consensus around large
problems I've become far less hopeful
than I was I mean when I think about the
prospect of convincing people about
climate change and then the need to
respond to it when I when I map on our
failure to respond to coronavirus with
the alacrity that was required when I
want to map that on to the problem of
climate change you know something that
is so abstract you know even in you know
with one hot year following another even
with one super storm following the next
when you can't really attribute any one
change in the weather to this you know
concern about climate and it's in
general just a slow-moving
catastrophe about which there's still
some some significant difference of
opinion you know even among scientists
you know not enough to discount the
problem but you know certainly more than
around the epidemiology of coronavirus
right and yet we can't even get on the
same page around this it's it makes me
think that the solution for for climate
change has to be surreptitious at this
point like this there is no political
solution we actually simply have to
design no products and and sources of
energy that people
find more desirable and you know we just
like you know the Tesla car is being the
perfect example like a certain point
people just people just need to want
electric cars more than they want
gasoline cars for reasons that have
nothing to do with climate just because
they're better cars and we have to
innovate on dozens of fronts in that way
and just do whatever we need to do to
mitigate the problem despite the fact
that we can't persuade anyone that is
even a problem because I the the
persuasion problem now just strikes me
as insuperable so that's kind of a very
pessimistic epiphany I feel like I've
had but I just cannot believe how hard
it is to talk to even very smart people
about what's happening with coronavirus
yeah it's it can be very disheartening
and not to say that I am right or
accurate and all things related to
coronavirus but certainly was have faced
a fair amount of flak for speaking
publicly about it which is totally fine
people have a right to disagree and I
suppose if I'm trying to look at the
silver lining in our inability to
communicate it might be a strange way to
put it is that perhaps our inability to
solve one problem like a pandemic will
in some ways help us to address early
slowdown man's contribution to climate
change because it'll just paralyze to
occasion and factories and many
different large-scale forms of sort of
cotton carbon carbon contribution to the
atmosphere so there's that you know it's
definitely improving our air quality for
the moment anything else that comes to
mind
that that you've ended perhaps another
word frame it would be anything that
you've been particularly surprised to
learn or excited to learn about in the
last year well this is something that we
you and I've talked about I don't think
in in public this actually would have
been the
we would have spoken about at South by
Southwest
but having psychedelics come back into
my life after what it was was definitely
more than a 25 year hiatus I mean it was
at least 25 years I think you know but
approaching 30 since I took up a
whopping dose of anything and I really
it wasn't really on my radar to do again
I forget what the proximate cause I mean
I'm certainly your own recent adventures
in that area we're part of it I'm
interested so getting sort of in the air
for it's been in the air for many people
in recent years but and I guess just the
fact that it's it's now a topic of very
promising research again significantly
inspired by by your commitment to it
you just excellent you have an excellent
podcasts interview on your podcast with
Roland Griffiths also yeah yeah he's
alright Johns Hopkins where he talked
about crocodile rape among others a rape
by crocodile I believe yes see the the
often unacknowledged threat of being
raped by a crocodile but happily I've
escaped that but I have not done DMT
that's one thing I haven't tried but yet
so I managed to convince myself to do
mushrooms you know a large a larger dose
a larger a larger dose of mushrooms than
I've ever done you know in the last year
and and again it been you know over 25
years since I had done anything
significant I hadn't done a lot of
mushrooms when I was when I was doing
psychedelics and I had done you know I'd
done them several times but never at a
very significant dose and never you know
blindfolded the way or in the dark the
way Terence Mckenna always recommended
it and I was a distant
fan of Terrence's for you know while he
was alive I actually met him once very
briefly and didn't actually know him but
yeah so I kind of view that as a missed
opportunity because he really had a a
beautiful mind and you know I've
listened to you know a ton of his stuff
and and he's just perhaps the most
entertaining speaker we've ever had on
any topic but I mean I should say that
probably half of what he said was fairly
crazy I mean he's like half of what half
of what you know the views to which he
was strongly committed I consider to be
fairly crazy and some some disproven
yeah he's very very entertaining yet
absolutely yeah
I mean he's a great he's a great example
of it you know almost not even matter
and whether someone's right because
they're just there's such a good speaker
but and he and he just again so I didn't
know him I just met him once very
briefly in 1992 and he died in 2000 so I
certainly could have hung out with him
and just just didn't and but that was a
period where I was I was getting really
into meditation and also I was taking
psychedelics but usually LSD and but
then I just stopped because you know
meditation became the center of the
bullseye for me and it still is but
after that many years I just felt like
there was something I wanted to
experience in the psychedelic space and
I recognized I had never taken mushrooms
in the way that Terence and others had
always recommended and so I wanted to
experience that so it was surprised to
decide it was suddenly relevant to do
that and then to kind of surprise to do
it and also you know very happy to have
had the experience I had and and find it
to be as useful as I as I found it to
pay so it was there was a kind of a just
a kind of reaming out of the pipes of my
mind that seemed very useful and I think
I will certainly do that periodically I
mean I think it's you know I didn't
come away from that experience feeling
like okay I never need to do that again
that was I'm done it really did seem
like a by no means the same thing as
meditation I mean it was it can be
easily harmonized with it but it's just
not it's just a different project on
some level because in terms of
transcending yourself getting rid of
this this illusion of being the subject
you know or being the vulnerable in a
little man riding that the horse of
consciousness you can do that without
any of the pyrotechnics of the
psychedelic experience and you know
conversely I'm convinced you you can
have a fairly transcendent you know
beautiful transcendently beautiful or
heroine depending psychedelic experience
without losing the sense of self you
know or at least you know it's not that
the experience isn't characterized much
by by a true transcendence of self it's
just your perception is vastly altered
and your your conceptual framework is
vastly altered but you're still a
subject
now either enjoying or suffering the
consequences of having your your nervous
system
you know driven from below by by the
pharmacology so it's it is different and
again there's no there's no
contradiction between them but anyway I
just came away feeling like yeah but it
kind of just renewed my interest and
commitment to it but it's hard to
imagine doing it in the current
environment I must say it's like there's
so much that is now being held in
abeyance by the this lack of normalcy I
mean I it's just I find it very
difficult to even articulate what seems
to have happened here I mean on some
level my day to day experience is
changed very little you know I you know
I count myself a very lucky as someone
who you know could I can basically do
all the work that was doing precisely as
I was doing it and be essentially
quarantined right a man you know I was
working from home anyway my team is
completely just
rivetted so there was there was nothing
to change there you know all my work
with them has always been in slack and
on the phone and by email and so it's
like nothing has changed and all I have
to do is release podcasts and you know
finish a book and it just it's all
nothing's changed but yet on some level
everything has changed and I feel like
we're you know I feel like I'm in a
spaceship where at any moment the breach
in the wall can be catastrophic
and it's um it's it's a bit a very
bizarre feeling which I know everyone is
sharing to one or another degree
question about your psychedelic
experience actually several the first is
related to a five minute or so maybe
slightly longer five to ten minute
afterward that you appended to the
Roland Griffiths conversation on your
podcast which was a description of your
five gram dried mushroom experience
which I thought was absolutely beautiful
is that available or do have any plans
to make it available outside yeah the
app yeah I think actually we're
we are just it's either on YouTube now
or it's going to be released with some
video backing to it I say it like a you
know something like you know great you
know cloud photography or something but
there's something you know it was just
an audio track but we've Illustrated it
with some video and then that should be
released very soon if it's not already
out great yeah what would people search
to find that what might they search
I'm sure it'll be on my youtube channel
and it'll be something I mean I'm sure
mushroom trip will be in the title Samms
excellent journey yeah not Sam not being
raped by a crocodile
Sam and not say Sam and Sam's excellent
journey yeah if you guys want the
crocodile rape details you're gonna have
to listen to the roland griffiths
conversation the second question was
related to carryover effects if any
that you have observed after recording
that description of your experience did
you see any persistent changes to your
perception behavior or anything else
not necessarily permanent but persistent
for a period of time whether days or
weeks did you observe anything like that
yeah it's um and this has always been
true of my experience with psychedelics
and you know unfortunately with it has
gone in both directions I mean so so
when I had you know back in the day when
I had some very unpleasant acid trips
which you know finally convinced me that
you're taking acid was essentially just
like a spin of the psychological
roulette wheel that you know you it's
just you just don't know what numbers
gonna come up and at that point the
negative side was coming up enough that
I just thought okay this really just
isn't worth it and it was especially not
worth it because I felt that the
knock-on effects of having that
experience for 10 or 12 hours lasted for
weeks and even months like I just felt
like that so when I would have a good
trip which is to say you know a truly
expansive beautiful trip you know the
the after-effects of that were in the
same register you know the I felt more
expanded and and and with a greater
purchase on you know a heightened sense
of beauty and that would last for quite
some time but you know conversely the
the kind of contracted neurotic kind of
shame encumbered space would either that
I would experience in a bad trip would
also leave some residue for some period
of time so I you know I felt like a
worse person for four weeks or even
months after some of those trips and so
that's why I kind of got out of the game
but you know the this trip was
you know almost entirely positive so
yeah as a kind of emotional and and
perceptual reference point yeah I felt
they a you know I felt better in in many
ways afterwards and I think I probably
still do I mean again it's not it's not
permanent in the sense that it's it's
not that it has blocked every other
state of consciousness from arising
thereafter I mean so I you know after
that trip which now is you know several
months old
you know I've experienced anxiety I've
experienced fear of experience anger of
experience so you know every everything
is still on the menu but as a reference
point it has stayed pretty vivid so it's
just it's easier to convince yourself
that like what when you've had an
experience like that
and this is this really is the the the
reason to take psychedelics even if you
are convinced that they're unnecessary
and that they're neither necessary nor
sufficient right so that they're there
maybe even if you're convinced that
meditation is the only way to really
transform your mind and the way that you
want to the thing about psychedelics is
that it can give you a me and as you
know you know each and in different ways
they can give you an experience of
states of consciousness which for which
there is no possibility of skepticism as
a meditator for the longest time I mean
for really for forever I mean so that
you use it they can torpedo the whole
project you can remain fundamentally
uncertain as to whether or not there's a
there there you know it's like is this
really gonna work is there really
something to notice here is there a mean
does life ever really get any better
than it's been in the last five minutes
you know is there anything to realize or
maybe I'm just fooling myself right like
all of it you can see you can cycle in
that space of doubt
for for years and years and and and get
absolutely nowhere but you know you know
five grams of mushrooms if nothing else
prove to you that it is possible to have
just an unrecognizably different
experience of consciousness and you know
that that's available given the
requisite stimulus right and there and
you know you're the drug doesn't get
your brain to do something that your
brain isn't capable of doing right it's
not like it's not like you've been given
a different brain the same serotonergic
system that is being leveraged by
psychedelics is you know always there
working for you and it gets leveraged in
every moment or not based on how you use
your attention and based on the kinds of
you know your the collisions you have in
the world and you know average is
everything else you're doing neuro
physiologically and it is it's just
absolutely possible to have a very
different moment-to-moment experience of
the world and and most of us i am i
consider myself among the the untalented
people who really probably just would
not have seen the merits of meditation
but for the fact that i had had a
psychedelic experience in that case with
MDMA which just proved to me that there
had to be there there that you know that
people you know in the various
contemplative traditions who were
talking about things like unconditional
love they weren't they weren't making
this up they weren't just epileptics or
frauds
you know these this there is so this is
a real continuum of human consciousness
that is there to be explored and you
just have to figure out how to make your
mind adequate to that project and and
psychedelics definitely reveal that it
is just incredible how different the
experiences can be on different
compounds even though they may fall or
be thought of as falling into the same
category of say psychedelics to take to
which are often thought of as as close
cousins and on some level they are
similar but you take say LSD which is
from a receptor standpoint quite
promiscuous with the duration of effect
that you mentioned which can be really
long right 8 to 12 hours which on one
hand it's tempting to say well that's
earth time it doesn't really matter just
like when people say oh I'm going to do
DMT because it lasts 5 to 15 minutes I
don't think that's the proper way to
frame the decision or think about it
because that that could feel like a
thousand lifetimes strung together in
terms of your your subjective experience
of those 15 minutes but nonetheless say
LSD just in terms of duration of effect
and then you look at say mushrooms four
to six hours generally there are
different species of course and all
sorts of variables what what I find and
what many people find difficult about
LSD there are there are a few things
number one it is so potent on a
microgram level that it is easy to miss
dose and the difference between a
hundred micrograms and two hundred
micrograms is hard to overstate how how
difference those two experiences can be
and that is a drop less than a drop I
mean depending on how it's being
administered right and then the I think
what makes for many people and I'd be
curious to hear your perspective on this
but mushrooms somewhat easier to
navigate is that the on ramp and the off
ramp the on ramp is a little longer
generally then then LSD so the the full
onset and peak of effects feeling at the
pharmacokinetics but the off ramp is
generally for most people going to be a
lot faster then LSD in the sense that
with LSD you might have and many people
do have
the experience of being fully journeying
in some transcendent psychedelic
experience dissolution of the self etc
for four to five hours and then there is
this tale of an additional two to four
hours and there are a fair number of
people who will have 24-hour Plus
experiences I don't know who knows what
the exact percentage of the population
is but having volunteered at zendo which
is a psychedelic harm reduction the
volunteer outfit at places like Burning
Man and so on you let's call it one in
30 people would be my estimate have a 24
hour plus response but let's just go
with the majority you have this tail-end
of two to six hours where you are not
sober you are absolutely not sober
you're still very malleable and
everything is intensified but you are
not journeying and so I find that that
in-between space can be quite
challenging to navigate because you're
know for a lot of folks that they've
taken the eye mask off maybe the music's
playing me or they're trying to eat
crackers with their friends and then
they have this huge surge of shame or
other intense emotion yeah but
intellectually they think that they are
in control so to speak right and that
that can cause all sorts of difficulties
that can persist as you mentioned yeah
when you're when you're eating a cracker
with both hands that's a telltale sign
that you're here you're not yet fully in
control yeah if you're holding your
Triscuit with more than more than eight
eight fingers it's probably a sign that
you're not fully sober yeah what was it
you know this this gets to an issue of
on some level mmm a dose that's too
small runs say a liability that that is
you know on some level even greater than
a dose that's too large or at least I
mean this the way I've
I've begun to think about it based on my
experience it's just the first we should
say that the four psychedelics like
psilocybin mushrooms and LSD you know
you're nowhere near a lethal dose of the
compound at any dose you're you're
liable to take you know even the most
aggressive and you know psychologically
destabilizing toast you know
physiologically is not likely to be
toxic for you so that's not an argument
for taking it as much as you can get
your hands on it's just that these are
physically very safe drugs and I would
definitely not say that of MDMA I'm an
MDMA you can clearly overdose on but
usually yeah you can clearly die
hyperthermia I've seen people in the
same volunteer capacity at different
events 100 and 405 degree temperatures
which is how you melt your brain and can
die certainly ibogaine or i boga also
can have some severe cardiac
complications and people do die of
cardiac arrests using I began and I
bogus so you really have to know your
compound psilocybin and LSD have
effectively no known ld50 meaning a dose
that would be it expected to kill say
500 of a thousand people in a room if
they were given that dose which can be
established for lots of things including
some common drugs like acetaminophen
which can be very dangerous so right
right so yeah so it's not and again I'm
sure people have had heart attacks and
strokes and other you know you even
fatal events on LSD or psilocybin and
maybe as a consequence of of what's
happening for them psychologically it
being part of that but it's just that
the we just know that the the drugs
themselves are physically very well
tolerated and so it's you know that so
that's not that the concern
but now I forgotten why I got into that
the let's see I was talking about the
duration of these two all right good
yeah so sorry then we're talking about
Triscuits eating it with ten fingers
right indicative if not being sober so
the reason so the reason to take more
rather than less for me or the reason
why there's kind imagining you're just
going to get your toe in the water I'm
leave aside micro dosing has its own
thing I'm not talking about that but
like that the reason why maybe five
grams of mushrooms could be better than
two grams of mushrooms for somebody is
that and you can you can do the
arithmetic for LSD there's that taking
enough reliably launches you past all of
your personal psychological content
right in the place I don't like to be in
the place I don't recommend people
spending much time is in the domain of
one's personal concerns life concerns
you know the kinds of thoughts that
precedes you when you're when you sit
down to meditate to get to stay on that
strata of your mind with with this
turbocharged experience of psilocybin or
LSD you know driving you there you know
that for the most part you you obviously
can have personal insights and you can
you can have kind of breakthroughs with
respect to your relationship to other
people you know I know that's the case
but generally speaking it is a recipe
for a lot of you know seemingly you know
very personal anguish which you can you
can actually bypass if you if you go far
enough out and then you and and and have
a have a truly you know transcendent
experience at least in transcended in
the sense that you're what you're in
contact with doesn't have a reference
point in your in your life right you're
not thinking about your mom or your wife
or your yeah be like for you on the way
out you
and on the way back you might be but
where you land when you know you're
actually at the peak is a place that
doesn't have those kinds of reference
points and again they connect it can be
very very beautiful or it can be very
very painful I mean it's not doesn't
guarantee a quote good trip but it's um
I mean that for me that's the real
opportunity of true psychedelic so
unlike something like MDMA where you
know to be working on your relationships
and to be thinking about specific people
in your life or even relating directly
to them you know that that is a seems
like a much a totally appropriate use of
that tool I agree I think indium is is
better described as an empath a jinn
yeah then a psychedelic I don't think of
it as a psychedelic at all there's
there's some dispute over how to apply
that term to different things but I
would I would add to what you said that
that the the analogy I use I guess
metaphor quite a lot when discussing
this with people is that of airplane
taxi and takeoff and the experience of
popping through the clouds so you have
this taxiing period you're waiting
you're waiting you have this
acceleration take off a slight amount of
turbulence and then very often as you go
through cloud cover you have even more
turbulence and then you pops through the
clouds and you have hopefully a smooth
ride or at least a ride from a very very
very different vantage point and to your
point about dosage if we're talking
about say mushrooms one of the
psychological risks of underdosing and
which is quite common because people are
understandably nervous and very often
this is done in settings where people do
not have a sitter which I always
recommend against meaning if someone
doesn't have a sitter they're likely to
want to dose more conservatively and in
doing so often take
something let's just say in the 1 to 2
gram range and end up stuck in the
clouds term in turbulence and they never
quite pop above the clouds into a
transpersonal or even if they still have
the identification of I the what
constitutes I changes quite a lot yeah
right in the second all experience you
can have complete ego dissolution you
can have complete what I would perhaps
called disassembly at higher doses where
your experience does not resemble your
ordinary waking reality in any sense
whatsoever you know time dimension
language all disappear I disappears etc
but ratcheting that down you can have
the experience of I Tim and experiencing
these various things but what
constitutes I and the boundaries that
normally exist in your waking life that
separate you cleanly from the external
world are very permeable very different
and the related point with say LSD is
that on the Descent instead of just
going straight through the clouds you
sort of hang out in the clouds or can
for a pretty extended period of time and
and that is where you can come out of a
beautiful transcendent experience and
this is not by the way a knock on LSD I
think it's a tremendously interesting
tool for the right people with the right
supervision but there is a tail end
where many people perceive their journey
to be over where very messy personal
material can come up with strong
emotional charge and they're simply not
they've taken their seat belt off and
they're going to get their luggage out
of the overhead compartment and crystal
and they're still in the clouds they
just don't realize it you know
so it's you know these things are very
very strong they're very they can be
very powerful so I always you know
advise caution with these things well
even in even in the best case when
you're talking about they come down from
less alst
let's say you've had a perfectly
expansive you know beautiful the
transcendent trip and then you're coming
down you know what I remember from those
experiences and probably the first ten
acid trips I took or literally had not a
single moment where I could even
understand what was meant by the concept
of a bad trip I remember being the guy
who was thinking what are people talking
about you know a bad trike it just there
was no I couldn't figure out where would
you point your finger to you know in
which direction could you possibly go in
that experience to wind up someplace bad
I mean just made no sense to me
and then then on some subsequent trip it
made ultimate sense it's exactly talk
about hubris but anyway so but even from
these trips I remember coming down the
experience was one of feeling my mind
encumbered by the the very you know
artifices and structures and diversions
of attention you know concern concern
psychological concerns on some level
that block the the expanse of experience
I had just had right so you know you
come down you you like one moment you
feel like Jesus and the next moment you
begin to notice the reasons the other
kind of rapidly accruing reasons why
you're not quite qualified to be Jesus
right and and and that any and if you're
in relationship to people I mean if
you're actually having a conversation
with someone who you were just tripping
with say you know that begins all that
begins to to fall into place in
with others in me and and you notice
your neurosis or at least your potential
for neurosis could to kind of get
reconstructed in front of you and you
know as you moment by moment and that I
remember that being painful I mean just
a witness kind of the capture of my
attention in something that you know
moments before would have been
unthinkable right and there you go from
Jesus to Woody Allen in your 60 seconds
we've got bad hair in either case you
know I just I just envy anyone with hair
that's right there's no there's no bad
hair yeah I I hope at some point I mean
it this this would be quite a distance
in the future I would imagine that we
will actually have scientific studies
looking at the combination of these
compounds for instance using MDMA or
other empathic ins there quite a few
that could be used as an on-ramp for say
LSD therapy or psilocybin and
combination therapy that I think could
be very very interesting we don't we
don't yet have the data we need and want
for these compounds in isolation so I
think that's a fair distance in the
future but I look forward to the day
when more of that can be done right
right yeah the one thing I'm looking
forward to which I mentioned at the end
of this this addendum that at the end of
the podcast with with Roland there's
there was that one study done combining
a meditation retreat with a high-dose
psilocybin experience and that for me
seems like a great marriage I mean just
to prepare people over the course of a
couple of days with mindfulness practice
and you know I'm sure there's there's
some way to to optimize this protocol it
wouldn't just be straight silence I mean
there might be some
in a reflection about you know what's
coming and then some integration period
but just actually systematize a a
retreat like approach to doing a a high
dose psychedelic experience that seems
very promising people who are doing it
because I'm just imagining I did a Sylar
treated spirit rock and there were 200
people sitting this meditation hall and
I was just thinking if you had 200
people doing a high-dose psychedelic
journey in one room it would be anything
but a silent order that's a very crowded
retreat it might not have been 208 but I
would say at least I mean at least 80
some are routine yeah yeah I think it's
about a hundred up there yeah yes so how
you physically and how you arrange the
environment and and how you keep people
in their own space and give them
adequate guidance and all of that I
don't know how that's brought off I know
they're there places that are doing it
there's one in Jamaica there was one in
Holland I mean a bunch of these places
this one in Mexico a bunch got in touch
with me after this podcast as far as I
can tell you none are really as as
lockdown and there there are protocols
as I am it they didn't seem like places
I could I could recommend based on what
I could see of what they were doing no
Facebook ads with your face for your
psychedelics anytime soon yeah
they may have someone may have produced
some but they're not they're not
authorized so you see any let me know
yeah one one comment I want to add as it
relates to difficult psychedelic
experiences or psychedelic experience
overall is there is a common pattern
among first time or relatively novice
users of psychedelics to develop
somewhat of a Messiah Complex after
they've seen the promised land yeah and
they have one experience or two
experiences
very often it's after one they have this
profound transformative experience and
they become a proselytizer for
psychedelic use and grandma you need to
do ayahuasca you know little little
Johnny nephew Johnny you need to do
ayahuasca etc which is at best
irresponsible and and also very very
dangerous and so my recommendation to
people who are experimenting with
psychedelics or considering it number
one the legal side effects can be just
as great as any other side effects so
I'm not advising Norris and that you
break the law secondly if nonetheless
you are going to experiment I would ask
that you put enough mileage under your
belt to at least once be as I sometimes
say to my friends tumbled and humbled
before you are given your card-carrying
capabilities of proselytizing
psychedelics it's my strong feeling you
need to have not what I would consider a
bad trip because I only distinguish
between safe and unsafe trips not good
and bad I think some of the most
valuable experiences you can have our
exceptionally difficult psychedelic
experiences in exceptionally safe
circumstances right but if if you're
simply getting the sort of unicorns
pissing rainbows version of the
psychedelic experience and those are
your first three or four innings keep
going possibly safely obviously until
you have a harrowing holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
experience it takes you a while to
digest and process before you run around
like the town crier telling everyone
that you do psychedelics yeah yeah I
think that's good advice because you
there's no way to appreciate how
difficult a quote bad trip can be unless
you've had one right and if you and in
fact if you've only had
good trips you're really you're almost
the worst judge of what is possible for
somebody else and yeah I'm for yourself
at some future time point so yeah I mean
that was I was actually one of those
people in him back in the day when I
first because I was taking psychedelics
the first time around before I was kind
of in this in this weird cohort because
I was you know in my peer group I was
kind of the only person doing what I was
doing I mean I you know when I would
when I would go on a meditation retreat
when I was you know 20 or 21 there were
there were no other 20 and 21 year-olds
on these retreats I mean everyone was
everyone had kind of been through the
60s and and you know so I was surrounded
by you know 40 and 50 year olds who were
who had been doing this stuff for 20
years or so and and so it was with
psychedelics so so when I got my hands
on MDMA would it had come out of well
you know X to say it come out of the
therapeutic community right after it was
a couple years after it was made
schedule one and but I didn't know
anyone I mean perhaps there were many
people my age taking it but I just
wasn't aware of it I didn't know anyone
who had taken it so when I got my hands
on psychedelics and meditation and
there's the the combination of all of
these esoteric things and kind of
rebooted the 60s for myself I was right
your private revival exactly you know I
was a one-man I was a one-man Grateful
Dead to her without ever getting into
the dead but I would just was not
meeting I just there was no one in my
world who who knew anything about any of
this stuff so yeah I was kind of
proselytizing and you know I got it you
know many people on on psychedelic trips
you know but I just
just branded myself somebody who was
qualified to do this after I don't know
a half a dozen acid trips and nothing
and nothing especially bad
happened but you know obviously I was
didn't have the the experience that one
would want to have to actually be doing
that and yeah it's um it's a little bit
like what happened to me when I when I
got into Brazilian Jujitsu I'm in the
moment I got into that I was like every
every conversation had to be a bad
person agency and that lasted until I
got you know injured and yeah so now I
know I have a slightly different
conversation about Brazilian Jujitsu you
should really just really try it oh wait
I didn't tell you last week I'm both my
came out torn
yeah asterisk yeah it's psychedelics are
still endlessly fascinating to me they
do not they have not in any way lost
their fascination for me so what about
in the current environment and can you
imagine tripping now or as just seem
like the wrong setting
well at the risk of being really
negligent or irresponsible I will say
that I cannot say with I'm gonna word
this like a lawyer would like I cannot
be a hundred percent confident that
there would be no value in a safe and
responsible use of psychedelics during
these times in part because these times
are not going to be this is not a it's
not too weak this is not a 90 minute
movie that we're watching this is this
is going to be an extended period of
time and I think there could be
applications for people who have a lot
of experience I don't think this is
necessarily the time to decide you're
going to find some homebrew instructions
for ayahuasca plus ingredients on the
dark web and do a solo journey into the
dark night of the soul I don't think
that's a good
by any stretch of the imagination but
for people with a lot of experience I do
think there there could be applications
there are probably more applications for
something like MDMA which allows you to
process a lot while not deactivating but
down-regulating fear response if that
makes sense part of the reason and I'm
not giving a neuro chemical or
pharmacological explanation here but
MDMA can be incredibly effective for
treating post-traumatic stress disorder
I mean some of the results are
unbelievable I mean if you look at the
studies maps has been designing and
funding and implementing in some cases
you have patients with 17 years median
17 years or 17 and a half years I think
this is from their Phase two trials
persistent PTSD severe symptoms who
after one or two sessions with MDMA
granted plus lots of integration and
prep and post work with you know very
highly trained generally highly trained
therapists who go from severe to
asymptomatic after one or two sessions
now that raises many questions and one
is how the hell can that possibly work
and I'm going to I'm sure bastardized
this and I should probably have Rick
Doblin on the podcast some point to
actually fact check and correct me on
things but I feel like I know what
they're doing pretty well and
subjectively I would say also from my
experience that MDMA in certain
compounds like it allow you to revisit
trauma or examine trauma whether lower
case T or capital T from a somewhat
detached observer perspective as an
adult so you can recontextualize and
process that trauma without reach Ramat
izing yourself
and that's not always the case and and I
should also say that
MDMA perhaps more so than psychedelics
is thought to be a love drug where it's
always running through fields and hand
each other flowers and that is not the
case
people can have tremendously difficult
experiences that require a lot of triage
afterwards and I've seen a lot of video
footage of actual sessions within the
context of training and people can have
a very tough time and this can this can
also open up Pandora's box where
afterwards people have said things for
instance they feel tremendous shame
about etc so it's not without risk there
are risks but for people who have
experience I think that MDMA could
possibly be a tool that helps them to
down-regulate fear and anxiety response
and process some of what is happening to
them in a way that allows them to be
more sort of proactive instead of
reactive afterwards that doesn't mean
I'm recommending people do MDMA right
now but I do think that if I had to
choose between MDMA and psychedelics
I'll probably choose MDMA all right well
I recommend that you wipe down the box
that the MDMA comes in oh yeah difficult
the question of procurement is a whole
separate a whole separate topic that is
probably best not discussed on a podcast
stay six feet away from your MDMA dealer
just lob the MDMA over the fence all
right so so that suppose those are a few
of my thoughts but people are struggling
right now people are struggling and I
think it you know in many respects
people are having a psychedelic millions
of people are having a psychedelic
experience right now in so much as this
set of crises and this pandemic has
acted much like
LSD is a nonspecific amplifier of
everything that's underneath the surface
and if you have mild anxiety disorders
or tendencies to anxiety they can be
managed under normal circumstances
there's a good chance that that is
magnified right now if you have a pen
well just think about forget about the
health concerns aside you know I I think
you and I are on the same page in having
worried up until this moment that that
people aren't taking the health
implications seriously enough that that
really the it hasn't been that we've
been too panicked by this it's just that
we actually haven't been worried enough
early enough to take the steps that we
need to take to actually get off these
exponential curves and and mitigate the
spread of this contagion but forget
about the virus if if there was just
some invisible force that we're having
the the economic effects that we're now
witnessing that would be a civilization
rattling form of stress for almost
everyone I mean you and I are in
uniquely fortunate circumstances in that
you know we're we're we're both well-off
and able to more or less work you know
almost it as we were before me you know
apart from not doing live events or
anything else yeah of that sort you know
we can more or less just continue going
but most people are not in that
situation and so even if there was just
no concern about the possibility that
you or anyone you love it's gonna wind
up in an ICU on a ventilator which is
gonna which is happening and it's going
to increasingly happen to to many many
people leaving all that aside you know
people are you know understandably
terrified about the economic volatility
we're seeing but you know it's it's not
just up and down and up and down it's
you know it's in certain sectors just
down and down
and down and down with no end in sight
you know if you look at the service
sector if you look at restaurants I mean
all of that is very scary especially
given the way in which I mean it
interacts with everything it was just
that the way in which our society is is
so lacking in resilience based on you
know they're not being a great safety
net even though we're trying to provide
one on the fly here with you know
trillions of dollars and there's a level
of wealth and equality that is is just
magnifying this problem and then there's
a political layer to it that is you know
increasingly toxic where you know one
side of the aisle is is you know fairly
delusional in this gritty which they're
denying the nature of the problem and
the other side is you know in in the
worst case just willing to make politics
out of out of a pandemic and it's like
we can't even talk to each other about
you know how to solve the most basic
human problems so it's it's incredibly
stressful you know leaving aside the the
actual reality of the pandemic it is it
is I've and and you're absolutely right
I mean we're in very fortunate positions
I have family members friends who've
been laid off from all types of jobs not
just service industry jobs I think the
service industry is the canary in the
coal mine and it's I've struggled you
know I've struggled with what to do to
maximally help also I think I've been I
don't think I know I've been sort of
beating myself up a lot about not doing
enough or perhaps not doing the right
things etc etc and there's a lot of you
have people in your life as it's been
happening
one-to-one where you have you know
friends and and family members who
you've had to burn a lot of fuel trying
to convince to take this seriously or is
it are you talking just about your
public messaging about it oh it's both
it's both I've you know I think that
because I discussed this publicly quite
early I want to say the first blog post
I put up about it was second or third
week of February which I caught a lot of
Hell for and then the campaigning for a
cancellation of South by which I caught
a lot of Hell for so that that was
actually quite easy because I was I had
a high degree of conviction that this
was inevitable
on some level given the mathematics
involved and the the the the the fine
details of the metrics could be off and
the case fatality rates and this that
and the other thing could be off but
even if they were off by 50% in either
direction nonetheless I mean the the the
picture emerging was very clear to me so
I felt good about that I think what's
been difficult is having many of the
people who initially didn't take it
seriously getting caught on their heels
in really bad positions with family
member family members to account for and
so on in different locations who then
came to me for help with everything and
I just I couldn't handle it I couldn't
and by not handle it I don't mean
emotionally I mean it was logistically
impossible hundreds of text messages and
it's just like I can't take six hours on
with each of these people to get them up
to speed it's not physically possible so
it's it's been challenging and I don't
mean to make it a it's not a sob story
because there there are many millions of
people who are gonna be having a much
harder time and I guess the the question
that that comes to mind for me to you
and is you know what would you recommend
to people who are scared or suffering
right now recognizing there are real
external factors to consider but also
recognizing that we often suffer twice
or suffer when we need not suffer at
least in our minds by imagining
worst-case scenarios
perseverating on worst-case scenarios
and being consumed by fear are there are
there any recommendations that you would
make to people who are fearful or
confused in these times I know that's
very broad and may be asking a lot but
how would you respond to that well I
guess the the place from which I'm you
know I can be fairly prescriptive it's
toward all the people who are in
situations similar to our own I mean in
the sense of you mean they're they're
people who are earned totally non
analogous situations to our own who for
whom you know the choice to stay home is
not impossible right right it would be a
an abdication of their own ethical
responsibilities if they were to stay
home I mean there are people who you
know need to work in our IC use and
they're people who need to deliver food
and you know keep the supply chain
running it's like all these people are
heroes for just doing their jobs
and so I view the ethical imperative to
get out of circulation
and not increase the the you know
disease burden and and the the burden on
our healthcare system you know that
falls to everyone else who can do their
work from home who for whom you know the
being out in the world is not actually
helpful to anyone and so those are two
very different sets of people and so you
know the people who are out there doing
the necessary work of keeping everything
running you know all of consider all of
them you know heroes whose way I want to
get out of write I want us all to get
out of their way and not make it any
more likely that they are going to get
sick or that they are going to be unable
to - if they're in health care you know
care for the people who are already sick
or you know soon to be sick or sick now
and don't know it
and but for the people who can reinvent
themselves or you know step away from
from their their careers and jobs and
and especially for the people who are
unfortunate enough positions to not
actually have to sweat the financial
implications of this in the near term I
just think there's there's a different
set of ethical considerations that come
online I mean just I think we we should
we should just be looking for
opportunities to help the people who are
more vulnerable than we are I mean so
you know if they're like all of us have
people in our lives who we employ
however peripherally you know I mean
just like take the person who cuts your
hair if you have hair I'll leave you out
of this Tim but I still have some of my
hair and you know so it's just like you
know I know how often I get a haircut
well I know I'm not getting a haircut
before I don't know when the next
haircuts going to going to happen but
you know why not you know buy some
imaginary haircuts here and and keep
help keep the person who cuts my hair
afloat during this period so anything
like that that you can think of doing
right to support people who you know are
taking you know in many cases a hundred
percent hit to their their economic
well-being
it just seems if you're in a position to
be able to do that you should write and
and that's and so you know I would just
advocate that we we recognize that we
are we're all part of a system here
we're all connected and you know in in
the most basic material ways and you
know we're all reliant on on everyone
else not breaking down and failing here
and and and so our effort to keep our
world together can't be solitary and we
can't be solitary at the national level
and it can't be solitary at the the
individual family level and ministers it
it can't be merely about making sure you
have enough food in your house because
you can't possibly have enough food in
your house so that you
are no longer reliant on the supply
chain and on the service worker who
would you know deliver the food from the
market that you're now is scared to go
to that person still has to have a
viable you know source of funds and so
anyway it's just to view our connections
to keep to keep our connectedness to the
people we know certainly and even the
people we don't more in mind here as we
as we hunker down as we should I mean
again I really do think it is an
imperative for us to to understand
collectively
I mean speaking as you know for them
with the country in mind I mean this
can't even be a state-by-state effort we
can't you know it's all of us who are
who are out of circulation now are more
or less just waiting for everyone else
to get the message because if this is
going to go on for a very very long time
if we can't extinguish it and slow the
contagion you know over the next couple
of months and it's only it's only by
doing that and then all the subsequent
you know testing and contact tracing
that we're actually going to return the
world and and the economy to something
like normal I mean there is there is no
rebooting of this economy with a
contagion like this raging and people
fall in sick in the numbers that they
will I mean we're just what we're gonna
do is just pendulum swing back and forth
from you know trying to restart the
economy and then realizing oh my god
this is just too scary then no you know
I just saw a crazy documentary about
what it what's really happening in the
hospitals and okay now I'm going back
into hiding and you know we're gonna
have that that experience on a
collective level over the course of
months and it's it's just going to be
needlessly costly in terms of lives and
our economic well-being whereas the
truth is we could resolve this in
something like a month if we had our act
together I mean literally we could lock
down for a month and this would burn
itself out if they did it correctly yeah
if they did that would require
isolating in fever clinics or elsewhere
family members who are positive from
their family yes sadly but yes or family
so even in a worse case than that just
you know everyone isolating in their
homes and then maybe the rest of the
family would get it and then you know
then whoever would have to go to the
hospital would go to the hospital but as
long as we're six feet away from
everyone other than our family members
and out of circulation we could that
this this thing could self extinguish
it's just we're not showing any kind of
aptitude for doing that because of it
just the nature of our political
conversation mainly yeah that but and
and to echo what you said a little bit
earlier my impression looking at the
confusion and hopelessness and
frustration among many of my friends and
this is not limited to people who are as
as fortunate as we are this is even lots
of folks I know who say are gardeners or
house cleaners who also want to help in
some fashion the question that I get
very often from top to bottom is which
nonprofit should I give money to and I
think that will become clear as things
progressed but right now there are a
thousand chickens with their heads cut
off running around trying to help and
really confusing things there are a few
signals in the noise I think flex port
flex port forward slash donate is doing
excellent work operation masks or guy
find interesting although I don't
understand all of it but there's a lot
of confusion and in the meantime there
are things as you said that you can do
to help just by focusing on the people
you know if you look back you're just
say a typical week from six months ago
what did it look like Monday to Sunday
and you can identify the coffee shop you
can identify the restaurants you can
identify
people you may have paid for god knows
what on a weekly basis a monthly basis
doesn't mean you have to feel obligated
by yourself to subsidize all of those
folks but what you could do is ask the
question that that I was I was was told
was the most important at the beginning
actually have a rafting trip my first
ever rafting trip and Kelly Starrett
who's an incredible guy
the readystate incredible PT incredible
athletic performance coach all-around
good guy and he used to be an Olympic
level kayaker and he said that everybody
was on the trip because he was
co-organized it he said the most
important four words that you can utter
are how can I help how can I help if
you're if if people are doing stuff and
your hands are empty how can I help and
what I've noticed at least in having
conversations with people I've offered
to help that oftentimes it's just asking
how can I help can I help you that is in
an of itself helpful does that make
sense it doesn't know how it doesn't
have to translate to them accepting your
help or asking for help but just
reaching out and making the offer and
indicating that it's a standing offer
even if they don't accept it now I think
is is tremendously psychologically
helpful so you don't have to wait for
the perfect nonprofit to present itself
you can talk to those people who you
already know yeah yeah and it's also
just worth remembering how disruptive
this emergency is and how unique it is I
mean this is a by its very nature this
is dividing us from ourselves I mean
this is this is separating people I mean
just think of what it's like to have
someone die now and you know the
decision about whether to have a funeral
or not I mean in most cases that it's a
straightforward decision of just not to
do that you know and and and just think
of the implications of that I mean the
rest of life is going on
you know and you know and all the bad
parts of life are still going on people
are getting sick and dying from causes
that have nothing to do with coronavirus
and you know all of that being made more
difficult than just you know deciding
whether you have to see a doctor for
some other reason now is incredibly
stressful and so there's just so much
going on now that it that it's people
are under a ton of stress and again it's
it's it's almost perfectly designed to
be hard to solve you know it's it's not
like initially the the analogy to
September 11th came to everyone's mind
just like this okay this is yet another
intrusion of history you know this is
another moment where we need to wake up
and realize okay the the society
destabilizing events are still you know
still on the menu right this is the this
is the kind of thing you're living
through now that people will be talking
about long after you're gone but on
another level this is this is totally
unannounced to September 11th I mean it
just it is it's much it's a much bigger
deal and it's much harder to respond to
intelligently it's not to say we
responded to September 11th with with
much intelligence but it's this is big
and and and no one alive has really gone
through something quite like this I mean
it's been it's this is outside of
everyone's lived experience you know how
to how to deal with this yeah and what
what I would add to that is that
I don't know if this will be helpful but
I speak from a personal perspective you
know I've been beating myself up for not
having clear frameworks for making
decisions not feeling clarity around
many things not knowing how to help
optimally or being able to figure it out
and the fact of the matter is it makes
very little sense for me to beat myself
up about that because it is not at least
not always reflective of a personal flaw
it's a collective experience that
millions of people are having right now
this is this is very different from
anything anyone living has ever faced
and that's not to say that the the world
as we know it is going to hell in a
handbasket I'm not saying that but the
the circumstances and the problems and
the challenges that have been created or
are very different from 911 or anything
else that we associate with national or
global crisis very very different so
it's I think helpful to try to remember
that
and I'm saying this as much for my own
benefit as anyone else to be gentle with
oneself and compassionate if you can be
because it's not difficulties the
difficulties that most people are facing
are not reflective of any individual
flaw they are reflective of a a
terrifying and unique situation and the
response of millions of people
collectively yeah oh yeah I mean there's
so many cases where it's not reflective
of a flaw at all it's just it's just
you're in a sector of the economy where
you know obviously you're getting zeroed
out right just because of the nature of
the problem it's like just imagine you
know owning the best restaurant in New
York City right you know you you may not
survive this interruption and your
activity through no fault of your own
you know it's
it's a this really is like a a stray
bullet on that level that just hits you
so you that's why we need I mean there's
there are silver linings here I mean we
need to to notice all the ways in which
our assumptions and our ideologies and
our you know our cherished notions about
how the world should be are not serving
us well here I mean they need to take
you know the fashionable ideas in in the
tech community a lot of people in tech
who are either avowed libertarians or
you know quasi libertarians or just you
know fans of ein Rand but they have this
basic idea that you know the government
is is useless and the less we have of it
the better we are really suffering under
a lack of effective governance now and
you know there are certain lessons here
that that should be indelible and one is
you know you can't rely on a piecemeal
private response to pandemic right and
you know it's not to say that the
immortal learning a lot about what's
wrong with the government and the
bureaucracy and the level of you know
red tape to cut through to actually do
something as simple as order masks and
and other protective equipment some of
the things that we're witnessing now are
absolutely bewildering the fact that
there's still a role to be played by
private parties in acquiring PPE ma you
know protective equipment for her
hospitals and and and first responders I
mean it's crazy it's like why on earth
does Elan musk need to buy ventilators
and deliver them to to the state of
California why isn't the state of
California in a position to buy those
Chinese ventilators or or you know
individual hospitals it makes no sense
and yet it's actually it's in this case
is not for lack of money it's just that
there's just a lack of agility on the
part of government here but whatever
systems we need to put in place for
next pandemic we really need to figure
this out I mean this this is as bad as
this will be and again I'm you know I
think you and I agree here that we're
still at the beginning of this thing
this is still a dress rehearsal for
something that could be much much worse
that on some level is guaranteed to
eventually happen you know whether it's
in our lifetime or not I mean that's
just it's just sheer good luck that
we're facing a pandemic that has the the
lethality of this one and not one that's
that's 10 or 30x this one so we have to
keep an inventory of all of the lessons
being learned here and and do better
next time and and so I mean there are
several silver linings here and we
there's a lot we are learning or at
least potentially learning and you know
that collectively in response to just
the need to have institutions that that
actually work rather than just populist
demagoguery that that appeals to half of
a society and the need to have you know
systems in place and and supply chains
and you know not not to be cut early
reliant on other countries to produce
you know necessary equipment and
medicine and I mean to had to stockpile
things that we know we will eventually
need or could need and massive
quantities I mean we're there to speak
of America in particular I mean really
the richest society that's ever existed
and you know we're scrambling to produce
the most basic tools at the moment it
makes absolutely no sense I mean it's we
should absorb you know on some level the
humiliation of this I mean you've got
doctors in the finest hospitals in the
country you know covering themselves
with bandanas it's madness and so we we
can't we can learn these lessons I mean
the on some level these are very simple
lessons and personally many of us are
having our priorities
jiggered around by this such that you
know we're connecting with with deeper
values you know in this experience and
you know and experiencing a silver
lining to it in just you know the way in
which we're prioritizing our time with
our family and you're just kind of
resetting or our you know career
priorities and I mean there's a there
are many good things happening for
people which are are not going
unrecognized maybe and it's just a
question of figuring out how to how to
maintain these these epiphanies once the
life starts back up again
you know well Sam I love our
conversations it's always nice to hear
your voice
and my boys we will have many many many
many many many conversations over the
forthcoming days and weeks and months no
doubt and I appreciate you and I
appreciate your thinking so thanks for
taking time in your day yeah well back
at your brother keep it keep it up here
we've been you know I think you
single-handedly got South by Southwest
canceled and it was the right thing to
do and you were I mean we sort of pulled
the ripcord together I mean maybe you
had pulled it earlier in your life but
like when you and I made the decision
you know when we were checking back and
forth with each other about you know
what was going to happen was South by
Southwest you know that was the moment
where I was understanding the situation
we're in and and you know you were um
you know I you were definitely the first
person in my life who was echoing back
to me the the the wisdom of of that
change in Outlook and so as as you know
thank you for being early on this and
and thank you for all that you're you're
doing because you you have been a great
source of information for a very large
audience and when you just need to keep
it up thanks so much Sam I I'll do my
best and it seems so weird to end this
way but I will how can people find you
where can people find you
what would you like to share before we
close up well they're really only two
places where I'm consistently making
noise I used to blog a lot and I don't
do that anymore I mean it's been it's
been years since I since I was writing
regularly on my blog but you do a blog
post on psychedelic where related to
psychedelics that's right
also yeah yeah oldie but goodie drugs in
the meaning of life which is in audio
form on on both of our podcast I think
it is but it's on my blog but it's in my
podcast is making sense and the the app
where I talk about all things related to
meditation and the nature of
consciousness and to some degree
psychedelics is waking up and that's
waking up calm highly recommended I use
it myself and Sam to be continued new
thanks again for taking the time and I'm
not sure what we mentioned that might
end up in show notes but if we have show
notes dear listeners they will be at tim
dot blog forward slash podcasting just
search Sam Harris or Harris or Sam and
they will probably pop right up and
thanks for tuning in Sam always always a
pleasure and I'll talk to you soon yeah
take care brother
all right gives you take care hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email for me would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by fresh books
thousands of listeners and a lot of the
contractors I use and my readers use
fresh books if you've been thinking
about turning your part-time side
business into a full-time small business
or big business for that matter you may
be feeling some extra uncertainty these
days and that's obviously completely
natural there are a lot of questions
that can come up how do you create a
professional appearance and experience
who can help you with support how do you
manage the billing and all of that
that's still focused on the primary
worth of your business and on growing
your business fresh books is an
all-in-one invoicing an accounting
solution does a lot more than that that
helps you take your business from
part-time to full-time and it only takes
minutes to set up they have one of the
best signup flows in the business I've
seen very few better they have been
helping people turn their passions in to
small businesses for 15 years and they
can help you too I've met the founders
have looked at this product very closely
with automated invoicing billable time
and expense tracking and an intuitive
dashboard that ties it all together it's
like having a full time financial
assistant with you every step of the way
you can create customized and sent
branded and professional-looking
invoices in about 30 seconds you get
paid up to twice as fast with fees as
low as 1% using ACH payments on fresh
books it's a fast easy and secure way
for clients to pay you for your work and
pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets fresh books apart is
their award-winning toronto-based
customer service a real person picks up
fast and will help you until you are
completely satisfied and have your
questions answered there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world right now but
your ability to build a business that
you're passionate about that you're
proud of doesn't have to be one
things business owners all over the
world rate fresh books is the easiest
accounting software to use try it out
check it out for free for 30 days at
fresh books calm slash Tim just enter
Tim Ferriss in the how did you hear
about a section again that's fresh books
calm slash Tim to check it out and try
it for free for 30 days one more time
fresh books calm slash Tim
[Music]
you
you
you
you